foreign
[Music]
hello everybody Welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Phillips Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists wow we are here
today with malabama hi guys C.K Coleman
is here what it is coming up today on
this free public minimal episode we're
talking to a listener about anger we
also have an outstanding lightning round
listener tip an added value segment for
you you can check out the full three
hour maximal edition of episode 357
where we answer four times the questions
and we dive deep into seven different
simple living segments that private
podcast episode is out right now at
patreon.com the minimalists your support
keeps our podcast and YouTube Channel
100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck from Alabama where
would you like to start today let's
start with our first question from
Anastasia Asia on Instagram what are
your thoughts on anger being triggered
by fear or sadness
hmm
anger's a funny emotion because you're
never just angry like it's that is a
Surface emotion okay so
um yes uh fear sadness being
misunderstood uncertain I mean there are
a lot of things that can create anger so
um I think that you know Anastasia is
just pointing out that like hey we get
angry for all types of reasons and
really the question is is like why are
we angry and is there something that we
can do about it or can't do about it we
were talking earlier with TK on the
private podcast I was talking to you
about how angry you made me last week
you made him angry and then I realized
in the middle of it like oh
it's not you who made me angry I made me
angry now how did I do that because I
had some expectations now you uh you
showed up sick and then didn't call off
but I didn't set that expectation with
you like hey don't come to the studio
sick right and so my real anger
this is an important lesson to me my
anger was at me
whenever I am angry I'm actually always
angry at me
dude that's why I rage so easily it's so
it's easy to rage against myself yeah
it's so much because like with other
people because like I don't like I've
never hit any wool in my adult life I've
never hit anyone out of anger when I kid
when I was a kid I'm sure I got into
some fights
um but uh but yeah man um because I
would never like lash out at someone
else but when it's me like all of a
sudden I have this permission because
it's me like oh I can beat myself up
um you can't fight back not against
yourself right exactly I lose every time
too and I treat myself really poorly in
those moments yes right yes because it's
too bad that's what we were talking
about with the previous caller Jamie I
don't accept things I want to change
them and we spend all of our time trying
to change things that we can't change
and then beat ourselves up for the fact
that I don't have the ability to change
the things I cannot change
um
yeah man yeah that's good if I could
have just just accept the fact that I'm
a shitty griller
maybe I wouldn't be so mad at myself
every time I grill I I end up raging
because like it's always either
overcooked or undercooked and then
Mariah oh my God God love her she was
like maybe we should get a meat
thermometer I'm like
how dare you recommend something so
sensible
I'm a man damn it I don't need a pizza
oh oh shoot TK you had something pithy
uh for this one I thought maybe we could
talk about it a little bit Yeah pithy
not pythy apologies to everybody I've
been saying piety you say whatever you
want man
that's right brother some people say
tomato
no they don't
yeah Josh is right keep it hey real
quick man what you said about acceptance
I I when I when I used to hear that word
I struggled a lot with words like
acceptance and contentment because I
used to hear like accept it as meaning
hey pretend like you're happy about it
or decree it to be a good thing and and
I and I had to realize that acceptance
means like you don't have to meddle with
it you don't have to mess with it you
don't have to force it into something
that it is not you can allow it to be
what it is and you can simply observe it
you can simply alter the way that you
look at it the way that you react and
respond to it and and I I think that's
an empowering way to look at acceptance
and I know that's what you're getting at
but for me that was a really hard thing
for me to learn because I looked at
being content accepting something as
meaning like pretending that you know my
mom not letting me go to that party is
the same thing as going to Disneyland
you know lying to myself yeah
my pithy for this one was anger is when
your heart says I feel passionate but
powerless
when I say passionate I don't mean
excited or inspired I simply mean
aroused riled up
my feathers have been ruffled I'm worked
up I've got a lot of energy flowing
even things like fear and sadness like
fear is when we feel powerless or
inadequate in the face of the unknown
sadness is when we feel powerless or
inadequate in the face of that which is
disheartening or disappointing and when
I say that anger is
I feel passionate but powerless it means
like I'm worked up about something I'm
charged up about something I've got a
lot of energy flowing and I either don't
know what to do with this energy or I
don't feel like I have the permission
and the power to do something with it
that feels right and
the way we have to deal with that is we
have to step back and make ourselves the
student of that anger and we have to let
that anger teach us not rule over us
like a master but let it instruct us
because just like with friends you've
got some friends who are really good at
making you laugh and you got some
friends who aren't funny they don't make
you laugh but they help impart wisdom
into your life your anger doesn't make
you feel good it doesn't make you laugh
but it's like that friend who tells you
what you need to hear even if it doesn't
feel Pleasant in the moment and this is
why I've sort of abandoned talking about
emotions in terms of positive and
negative emotions positive and negative
emotions are like positive and negative
numbers it it says nothing about the
quality of what we're dealing with these
are just labels right is is negative
five a bad number you know no it's it's
relation to what yeah it's just to the
left on the number line right and is
anger a bad emotion is frustration a bad
emotion we say it's bad because it feels
bad meaning that it feels uncomfortable
but it's actually a very useful emotion
and if you can learn how to not resent
those feelings then you can let go of
the resistance that you have to the
wisdom they provide and the how-to here
isn't a prescription it's not like you
can follow the four steps first you do a
hundred jumping jacks and then you do a
backflip and then do some box breathing
right five seconds and so the reason or
the way rather that you
change the emotion is you allow it to
change by observing it
because that's how you stop clinging to
it it's easy for us to cling to the
anger to the fear or whatever else and
it snowballs it gets worse and worse and
worse why because I'm not observing it
I'm mistaking myself for the anger
instead of uh I am angry perhaps the
well the
more loving approach is
anger has appeared within me yeah yeah
because you can see as we had uh Dr
Susan David on the podcast you talked
about emotions aren't
good or bad their data and what is that
data telling you
because I think we get confused and we
think we want one thing we think we want
Perpetual excitement and happiness
forever that's Mania because it
continues to amp up and up and up it's
the reason that Hedonism doesn't work
because eventually you bought you've
bought your second yacht what am I going
to do with the first one now right and
so these things aren't actually bringing
me pleasure and you could scale that all
the way down to a pair of tennis shoes
right someone thinks buying the new
Jordans are going to make them happier
they might be aesthetically pleasing to
them
and they may even amplify the happiness
that's in you right but they will never
make you happy I think we have to
understand that because as we cling to
the idea that everything should always
be exciting I don't think we always
think it through because let's say that
everything was pure excitement for every
waking hour of your day that would drive
you insane and so you'd think you want
that but as soon as you got that it'd be
like the dog chasing the car you'd have
no idea what to do with it and it would
probably run you over it's manic that's
manic man you're on the street directing
traffic because you think you have a
better way I mean there's plenty of
people out there who
armanic and I do not envy them at all
um
TK the what stands out in your minimal
Maxim for me is the word powerless
because I think I'm thinking all the
times I've ever been angry in my life
and it is always a feeling of not having
control over something
um it makes me think about
instead of uh fostering this feeling of
not having control
maybe it's more beneficial to just
accept like you know what no I don't
have control
and that's okay
and uh yeah I don't have any power right
here and no I can't I can't make TK not
come in when he's sick I can just ask
him and then and then he goes from there
like I don't have power over you know
over anything really
um but it is interesting because there
is something with anger it
I dare say a hundred percent of the time
it comes it comes back to I don't have
control over this situation and and now
I'm raging because I don't have control
and we're still not thinking it all the
way through either because let's say you
did get that power you got absolute
power and could now manipulate every
person right
well that's not what you want either
that's not a human interaction that's
interacting with some sort of AI I've
programmed you to do everything I want
you to do that turns into absolute
certainty and that's also going to make
me angry at some point angry that
there's no variety angry there's not
that delicate dance of tension you know
when you're flirting with someone for
the first time and all there's that
tension there are they going to like me
yeah I don't know I don't have power
here so it's not that you actually want
power in every scenario because you
wouldn't know what to do with it anyway
if you had absolute power you would try
to get rid of it to add that variety
back into your life yeah and then you'd
be hey you could still be angry at
people for needing you to change them ah
this idiot I'm gonna have to change them
too just so angry that I have to do it
but you know this this notion that anger
is bad is it has a strong grip on us and
it's very very seductive as as an idea
to to look at look at our anger as if
it's evidence that we're failing and I
think about the old adage that says you
can't stop a bird from flying over your
head but you can stop it from making a
nest in your hair I think that's a good
sort of analogy for anger anger as a
sensation that comes and goes as a
natural part of the human experience and
anger as a condition that you have
identified yourself with you can't stop
yourself from being a human being who
sometimes observes experiences that you
don't like and that cause that feeling
of anger to pass through you but you can
prevent it from occupying your soul and
making it your permanent home and being
someone that is ruled by rage and don't
get mad at me y'all I'm only responding
to a very popular source of thinking
about this because there are a lot of
people a lot of the biggest resistors to
this idea are people who quote the Bible
a lot of the biggest champions of this
idea people quote the Bible they said
well the Bible says you shouldn't be
angry the Bible actually says be angry
and sin not you are going to have
moments where you feel frustration but
don't miss the mark don't react and
respond to that frustration in a way
that is unhealthy it says Don't Let the
Sun Go Down on your wrath you will have
moments where you feel upset with people
but don't let the day end like that
clear it up get it right process those
feelings reconcile yourself with your
brother and sister and let it go and
start a new day with new Grace
um it's the only way you can start the
new day is by letting go because we
bring all that stuff
into our next day then it's groundhog
day except it gets worse every day
because that anger builds and builds and
builds Anastasia I want to send you a
copy of our book everything that remains
Ryan and I wrote this 10 years ago this
year Ryan we move out to that cabin in
the middle of nowhere Montana there was
one traffic light in 3 400 square miles
and we uh we lived there for like a five
month period negative 26 degrees when we
woke up in the morning and all there was
to do was write we wrote this book about
everything that remains and it was a
story about letting go of our old lives
so we could move forward into something
more meaningful a narrative Memoir if
you enjoy our podcast I think you'll
enjoy the audiobook version of
everything that remains or if you want
the book book or the ebook version
Anastasia will send those to you as well
Ryan what time is it you know what time
it is it's time for the lightning round
where we answer your text messages you
can text your questions your comments
your compliments to
937-202-4654 yes indeed now during the
lightning rounds where we do our best to
answer questions with a short shareable
less than 140 character response we put
the text to these minimal maximums in
the show notes so you can copy and share
our pithy answers on social media if you
like and you can find all of our minimal
maxims in one place now
minimalmaxims.com TK had an idea about
this to keep the lightning round short
he's giving us a 60 second timer with
our answer let's do it and then
Professor Sean is going to give us a
buzzer if we go over okay our 60 seconds
from Alabama our question today is from
Gloria my boyfriend and I just bought a
new house and his relatives are already
sending us big furniture I don't want
but he does how do I handle this all
right start the timer Professor Sean
here's what we do
here's my pithy answer for you Gloria
every relationship is a doorway to
misery
and joy
quite often we bring someone into our
life because we think that person is
going to fulfill me they're going to
complete me they're going to satisfy me
they're going to make me happy we're
mistaken we are wrong because what's
going to happen is they're going to
bring out the best of you or if we make
the wrong connection they're going to
bring out the worst in me well why do
they do that because I've heaped a load
of expectations on you you should be on
time you should dress like this you
should talk like this you should behave
like this you should like the things
that I like and if I have those
expectations of you man it's going to
make me miserable
he came home
TK common with 60 seconds for the first
time in his entire life I feel like it's
on figures I can't see I gotta do this
to see the clock
I didn't even look at it just start my
clock now my my Maxim is every unwanted
gift is an opportunity to be generous
you got two ways you can do this number
one Santa Claus built an entire Legacy
off of unwanted gifts why because he
takes things that he doesn't want or
need and he finds people who does need
them and he gives it away to them please
do not leave me a comment in YouTube
telling me that Santa Claus is a
fictional character because I don't want
you to make yourself look like someone
who believes that truth cannot be
Illustrated through fiction okay the
second way that you can do this is when
someone in your life wants to keep the
gift you can be generous towards them by
getting curious about it and using it as
an opportunity to build a connection
with them and understand why they value
that thing don't debate them don't be
defensive say hey why do you want to
keep this why do you love them so much
and enjoy the conversation
yeah yeah
ladies and gentlemen Ryan Nicodemus oh
uh my pithy answer is this big decisions
with little discussion creates big
disappointment and Gloria I love you
thanks for listening to us
we are not the men to be asking what's
going on
um like the person to be asking what's
going on is is your significant other
and it's a hard conversation but you
gotta have it and if you do it in a
loving way with the non-violent
communication like you'll you'll
probably work it out my guess is that
your husband loves you and wants you to
be happy and you'll see that through
through this conversation you're gonna
have with him
I'll tell you one rule that I have since
we had a little extra time here one rule
that I have in our house that works
really well for me and Bex we don't
bring anything in unless we both agree
on it there were two things that we
wanted to go over in fact I'll go over
with you on the private podcast here in
a bit with the impulse purchases we
tried to buy something but she didn't
want it and I wanted it so we said no to
it and then two days later she wanted to
buy something and I just didn't like the
aesthetic beauty of it got her back
didn't you
he's like Vito and I really wanted it
too I would never do that because that
would make her angry right yeah but we
talk it out and I'm also willing to make
concessions but we both agree before we
bring something into the home and if you
could set up a rule like that Gloria I
think it'll it'll help you out in your
yeah that's awesome that's awesome all
right Alabama we got some other segments
to get into what else you got for us
here's a minimalist Insight from one of
our listeners hello this is Morris
Bradley and calling out of Tampa Florida
and I just wanted to bring up a line of
thought in regards to the selling part
of decluttering when it comes to
minimalism the first half is a list of
price points to consider when selling
some of your unused stuff and the second
half is the philosophy behind why
letting go is okay even when you may not
be 100 happy with it so here are five
price points to remember and consider
when reselling an item one the price you
paid for it sends tax to the used price
stands tax which is always half the
original price this is what most people
want out of their items but it's not
what they'll always get
three the market price for similar items
for the price the consumer wants to pay
for the item and five the price you want
or will settle for when it comes to the
item
one thing to remember is that you don't
actually own anything
that may be a difficult concept to grasp
but let me explain
everything you buy is a remaining
lifetime rental meaning that when you
are no longer here your lease is up and
your stuff is not coming with you
where it goes from there is up for you
to determine while you're still here
but let's say you get a brand new couch
for 500 and use it for five years
you may not get 250 out of it you may
only get 50 to 100 but even at that you
have the experience of owning that couch
for better or worse in the if you
discount the amount you resold the couch
for you can count that as how much you
initially paid for it and if you do feel
bad about spending as much as you did
initially
taking off that 100 can help you feel so
much better
so way you say if this is a remaining
lifetime rental what happens when I
break the lease and I resell it
now that's actually a really fun part
because most times when you break a
lease you have to pay a b but in this
scenario you're actually getting paid
but anyway I found that looking at
things this way has really helped me
declutter and let go all right y'all
let's move on to our added value segment
before we get to that real quick right
here right now here's one thing that's
going on in the life of the minimalist
we've changed the name of our newsletter
it used to be the simple Sunday
newsletter but we found that we were
sending it out on Wednesdays or
Thursdays
Josh's OCD of course kicked in
it made me angry
and so we just simply called it you're
the one who schedules it
well I told you that's all this whole
episode's been about we've been doing a
private podcast for three hours now and
it is merely me who angers me always TK
you don't have the power to anger me I'm
taking back the power and now
ah
I'm still pissed to shoot off no no tell
them why you mad son all right we call
this the simple newsletter now we simply
change the name to the simple newsletter
you can sign up for it at www dot the
minimalist.email you can find it over
there or you can just go to the
minimalists.com and enter your email
address at the top two options there
every Monday when our episodes come out
we'll send you our show notes in your
inbox for free all of our minimal maxims
all the pithy or pythy stuff that TK is
saying we'll put that there in your
inbox all the links to things that we've
mentioned as well and then on Thursdays
usually we'll send you something whether
it's a new minimalist writing in form of
an essay or maybe it is a sample video
five minute clip from the private
podcast a standalone clip that will add
value to your life
just sign up for the email list over the
minimalists.email you can pick if you
want both of those or maybe you just
want the show notes maybe you just want
the simple newsletter you get to decide
we respect your inbox like it is a
sanctuary we're not going to send you
any nonsense no ads No Junk no spam ever
we're very considerate of your inbox we
never sell your information to anyone
else either for added value this week I
just finished watching
the finale Better Call Saul I love hope
don't spoil it yeah so it's funny I have
been saving it because I hate the
Cliffhangers so I've been waiting for it
to be done and it finished while I was
in Montana I didn't really have time to
like sit down and like you know get some
episodes in
but um anyway I I love it because you
gotta you got it yeah even great without
a TV so how did you watch Better Call
Saul Milburn so I don't have internet at
home I don't have a TV at home so what
Bex and I would do is I would go to a
coffee shop and download the episode and
on my little 11 inch screen we would
watch uh you look at me like 11 inches
small right
I don't even know what 11 inches looks
like Josh compared to what
[Music]
here's what I noticed from and I won't
ruin it for you here's what I'll say
though it's personally my second
favorite show of all time it's great I
uh I like that whole universe and I
think people are even out there having
the Avatar syndrome remember that where
people like wanted to be an avatar oh
yeah yeah and they would they've missed
the Avatar and they wanted to live in
the movie yeah I've heard people were
saying this now but I wish I lived in
Albuquerque in this universe and I'm
gonna miss the characters I totally get
missing the characters right I didn't
love the ending I'm not going to spoil
it at all and some people absolutely
loved it but here's what I'll say about
the show
here's why it was full of versamillitude
for me which is a fancy nerd word that
means it felt real right it yeah it
makes sense and here's why it felt real
because in my 20s I wasted most of my
20s pursuing this image of success and
the Saul Goodman we saw in Breaking Bad
was sort of the epitome of this he was
the Terminus of it like gold-plated
toilets and giant marble walls and a lot
of it was faux marble but even if it was
Rio you realize how unhappy this person
is and all of this accumulation was not
masking his discontent in a way it was
even making him more discontent because
the chasing you know the root of the
word agony the etymology of the word
agony just means to strive so the more
we strive like Saul Goodman
Trove Drive
can we get a vote on this professor Sean
what's the capital of scraped
get out of my studio
Professor Sean teaches how to write
better with me uh the online writing
class anyway we uh uh what I realized
throughout my 20s is I was striving no
wonder I was in so much Agony I couldn't
stop striving and so we often think of
striving as a quote unquote good thing
but sometimes oftentimes most of the
time one might argue all the time it can
lead to Agony man it's so funny because
like I know where that show is going
like if you saw breaking bad you know
what he turns into you have no idea
where it's going that's all I can say oh
well I guess what I'm saying is is like
you know the Terminus of what Saul
Goodman turns into so how he go how we
don't that's the thing all right don't
don't say anything else because then I'm
going to start guessing no other
spoilers but let's just say you will
enjoy it because you'll get to be
immersed back into that Universe once
again interesting did they do a Marvel
thing and do like a parallel universe
thing
different dimension I have no comment
all right that's funny hey uh one bit of
commentary when I wasting my 20s being
successful just that thing yeah
this is one of the greatest fears among
teenagers today the fear that they're
going to make a decision that leads to
them looking back on their lives one day
when they're 30 saying oh no I did the
wrong thing I wasted my life pursuing
the wrong thing
and there are a lot of movies and TV
shows that have been done where maybe
somebody makes a deal with the devil or
they they have a genie in the bottle and
they're able to see the future
and the moral of these stories is always
the same that when we know too much
about the future we try to prepare for
it in the way that seems the most
reasonable today and then we negate the
future of all of its meaning
if you had known when you were 20 that
you would be a minimalist that you would
have this podcast that you and Ryan
would do this and that
you would have probably said something
like oh well since I'm gonna do that let
me just prepare for it in this way yes
you know like if if if I had some
crystal ball that says hey in 10 years
you're going to be a doctor I would be
like whoa that's weird I couldn't
predicted that well I guess I better
just go to med school now and start
preparing for it because that seems
reasonable to me but what makes a human
story interesting is that you get to the
Future by taking seriously what lies
before you today right it's it's the
fact that that dream you have today
which isn't gonna come true you think
it's gonna come true you believe that
it's gonna come true and and you feel
inspired by it and that's what you have
to go off of you can't predict what
you're going to like or be interested in
when you're 30 or 40 and try to figure
out the intellectual puzzle of how to
live in a way that that person is going
to approve of you've got to face the
reality that's in front of you now and
go after the values that you have today
always being open-minded and when you
get to that future and you look back and
you judge your past from this higher
standard of wisdom
you have an interesting life because you
took seriously the preferences
principles and priorities that you had
at that time yeah
I I don't know a 30 year old or 40 year
old or 50 who doesn't look back
at some decade in their life and be like
what was I thinking I mean it's it's
funny because like I would say to that
you know that high schooler or you know
young college student like
but you're gonna look you're gonna be 30
and look back and you're gonna wish you
did it differently but yeah but if you
can take seriously what you have in
front of you maybe you'll have uh a
little bit less critique on your life
but there's like I don't there's
probably an exception to this rule
there's probably someone who's like nope
I I was born winning and I'm 80 years
old I pretty much won every day of my
life made all the right decisions great
but that is that is that is a that is a
uh
I want to say it's like a fiction for
the most part like everyone's gonna
everyone's gonna come across a time
where they're like oh I should have done
it different and that's okay that's part
of it yeah absolutely I'm sorry uh but
no you know like if you believe in the
possibility of learning what that means
is that at some point in the future
I'm gonna know things that I don't know
right now
and that means that future knowledge is
going to cause me to look back today on
all the things that I'm doing and saying
and go oh
if I could go back and do all that over
again I'd be so much more wise about it
that's necessarily true if I continue to
learn and grow what that means as much
as crazy as it sounds that means right
here and now I'm wrong about something
and I don't even know that I'm wrong
about it
right here right now there's something
that I'm gonna look back at on the
future and be like Oh TK I hate that you
said it that way or oh TK you were so
off you were so overconfident about that
that's necessarily true about me today
and I don't know what that is but I
can't live my life in a fear that you
know I I can't speak because in any
given sentence I might be wrong about it
and I'm going to figure that out in five
years and come back and condemn that
sentence I've got to speak as I believe
right now I've got to express myself
honestly in accordance with how I think
right now and continue to be open to
growth in the future
by the way we got a bunch more surprise
questions this week on the private
podcast like what should I do when I get
pissed at my husband because he never
does anything on his to-do list
how does jfm approach his OCD as a
superpower when it causes tension in his
life why did Joshua get very mad at TK
Coleman last week we're going to talk
about that plus a million more questions
for the minimalist and if you want to
hear all that malabama tell them what to
do check out the minimalist private
podcast visit patreon.com the
minimalists or click the link in the
description to subscribe and get your
personal links so that our weekly
maximal episodes play in your favorite
podcast app you'll also gain immediate
access to all of our archives recordings
of Live Events weekly home tours and our
private community of thousands of
active-minded minimizers like you in
fact here's a thoughtful testimonial
from one of our lovely patreon
supporters
more coffee please says wow I just
became a private podcast subscriber and
I feel like I got my soul's worth from
just one episode how to be satisfied I
have bookmarked this episode to return
to frequently as I need constant
reminders about taking deep breaths and
gently stepping off of the craving
treadmill thank you thank you thank you
if you have a question or comment for
our podcast give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at theminimalist.com you can
follow the minimalist on Tick Tock
Instagram Facebook and Twitter at the
minimalists that's right now on behalf
of Ryan Nicodemus from Alabama TK
Coleman podcast Sean Jordan no more
Professor Sean social justice Danny
unknown post-production Peter Emma The
Immigrant and the rest of our team I'm
Joshua Fields Milburn if you leave here
today with just one message
please let it be this
love people
and use things because the opposite
never works thanks for listening y'all
we'll see you next time
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without it